thousands of rescuers are working
nonstop in Mexico this morning looking
for survivors of the 7.1 magnitude
earthquake more people were pulled out
of collapsed buildings overnight
searchers are digging through the ruins
of an elementary school in the capital
where one girl is reported to be alive
but still trapped 25 people died there
the overall death toll from Tuesday's
quake is now at least 245 Manuel
Bojorquez is in Mexico City man well
good morning good morning this afternoon
will mark 48 hours since the earthquake
struck so not only is time working
against rescue efforts there are also
also hazards we've been monitoring the
situation at this collapsed office
building where crews told us this
morning they're trying to shore up the
remaining bottom floor because they fear
it could give way dramatic rescues like
this one happened all across central
Mexico Wednesday first responders pulled
several victims alive from the rubble
they've become symbols of hope for those
still searching for their missing loved
ones a Hindu scout who are you looking
for
[ __ ] her husband Martha Lauda prayed
with a rosary for her husband of 15
years he's an engineer and just this
Monday began working at a building that
collapsed it would be more get rid of it
it's the last thing you give up is that
what we seek was for your children
at a destroyed elementary school
rescuers worked through the night trying
to free a little girl still trapped
beneath the debris they believe there
may be more children inside but time may
be running out to save them hundreds of
volunteers joined the rescue efforts
every so often they raised their fists
asking for silence so first responders
could listen for sounds coming from the
wreckage volunteer Alex Osorio is a
banker who helped save four people from
this office building you see the
families and you're very worried about
the agent you're trying your best but
that has got to change so far more than
50 people have been rescued from
collapsed buildings here in Mexico City
but there's another factor complicating
matters it rained last night and there
is more rain in the forecast for today
Charlie Manuel Bojorquez in Mexico City
thanks man Manuel